do you think of the the idea of trying
to either silence you or make you
irrelevant is working meaning do you
think you're more relevant today than
you were on September 1st is that
strategy they're implementing uh working
no they're failing and the reason
they're failing is because God's put me
in a position where I have to leave from
the front
I I think that
in the days of old when politics used to
mean something politics I believe in
politics as long as the leader of the
country charges on his horse of the
Enemy at the front then you're allowed
to be king then I'll listen to your laws
that's politics when you send other
people's kids to die in a war and you
sit on your ass that's not politics to
me but now I'm in a position where I'm
spearheading by God's plan the rights of
basically every man on Earth they could
do this to anybody so I think any man
with a brain who's thinking is looking
at my position and going it could hit me
or my friends or my son or my dad the
same way they're hitting this guy and
that that builds a degree of affinity
among small audience so no they failed
they failed they've made a hero out of
me which is what I'm actually scared of
I'm I am scared by the incompetence of
my enemy I'm scared by the fact that
they are failing so monumentally if they
had been half successful with the
cancellation none of this would have
happened if the cancellation made me an
obscure internet personality it'd be
over if I would have just allowed them
to beat me
none of this would happen would I beat
them
and that's the problem now I'm sitting
here going okay well after I beat you to
BBC after I destroyed the BBC Tristan
gave me a high five he's like oh you
wrecked they're gonna look so stupid I
said bro we've sunk the HMS Hood HMS
Hood in World War II HMS Hood was the
British battleship is it the the
flagship of the royal Navy and the Royal
Navy was obviously renowned it has been
for hundreds of years it was the best
Battleship and it was up against German
battle Crews of the Bismarck and the
hood should have outgun the Bismarck and
it was the best German ship against the
best British ship by absolute fluke the
Bismarck on its first volley or second
volley landed a shell perfectly through
the top of the hood and blew up the ammo
magazine and like in the first shot
within minutes destroyed the entire HMS
Hood chilled like I think it was like 3
000 people two survivors you can find
the video on YouTube the hood blow into
pieces when Churchill found out the hook
was sung he said sing to Bismarck don't
care what it costs he sent every ship
every plane every sub diverted from
every other Mission doesn't care if we
lose every plane we have don't care if
we lose the RAF we cannot lose the hood
without him losing the Bismarck Sink the
Bismarck when the Bismarck sunk the hood
all of the crew were celebrating except
the captain the captain updated his will
he updated his will and telegraphed home
to his wife and said goodbye because he
knew when I destroyed the BBC my brother
was celebrating I knew I said Tristan no
you don't beat the British Broadcasting
Corporation to make fools of them like
this without some new we sucked
the hood and he's like oh we'll see oh
who's this Evie Evie Evie I knew
it I'm winning too well I'm scared by
the incompetence of these class but I
don't know what else I'm supposed to do
am I supposed to lose
I'm genuinely looking for guidance here
am I supposed to roll over and
lose when they're lying about me and
slandering my name and trying to put me
back in a dungeon back with the
Cockroaches all I could do is protest my
innocence but there's such idiots I make
them look so stupid and then there's
egos involved you think the you think
the you think Lucy Williamson hasn't
been called into a meeting room with
some BBC producer saying you made a fool
of us yes she has there's egos involved
big big businessman with business
interests of ego investment and hurting
me now and I keep winning so I don't
know I'm in a very precarious scenario
do I continue to win do I do I let them
win a bit do I just roll over and shut
up what am I supposed to do I don't know
what the right move is it's difficult
so you sincerely don't know what the
right move is I sincerely have decided
that the best thing I can do is stay
true to my faith and stay true to God
and tell the truth and fight
the right move for me I believe is to
fight and and fight to the end because I
think that suicide is always the wrong
option I believe you're put in a bad
position the best thing you should
possibly do is fight for the best of
your ability which is what I'm going to
do however
if I was looking at it purely logically
without any kind of ideological
motivations perhaps if I would have shut
up when they wanted me to I wouldn't be
in this scenario but that's just not who
I am
you know Alexander the Great didn't have
to keep conquering Genghis Khan didn't
need to take Vienna he could have just
chilled he kept going
so I feel like when I'm in a position
where I don't know what I'm supposed to
do the best thing I can do is just look
to God and tell the truth and just and
that's what I'm doing my neck is an
application which allows you to take a
minute to connect with influencers from
all around the world my name is Andrew
Tate and I'm available to speak directly
to you on minute so if you like this
clip and you want to watch another one
click right here and if you want to
watch the entire podcast click right
here
[Music]